In this class we discuss different ways
of showing information to the user.
But you might be confused as to
which is the most appropriate for
different situations.
See here's a quick run down of when
to use each one of the following.
Notifications, regular activity,
always-on activity or watch face.
Let's discuss why you'd
use one over the other.
Notifications are best when you need
to get the user's attention right now.
You have a picnic coming
up in ten minutes so
you need to do something
about this straight away.
The information will probably
be out of date after an hour.
Notifications will cause
the wearable to vibrate ensuring
the user then glances at the device
to see what they need to know.
Regular activities are great when
you need to take care of some
action right now.
Such as sending a text
message to a friend.
You want the activity to take over the
whole display, show what you just spoke,
send the message, and then disappear.
You might also want to get more detail
about the weather for the week.
You can scroll through a list to see
what the temperatures are for each day.
But this is not something you want to
always be visible when the user is busy
doing other things.
These regular activities will disappear
when the watch goes into ambient mode
and the default watch
face will then be shown.
Always-on activities are special
because when the watch goes into
ambient mode after a timeout,
the app continues to run but
the display goes into a low power mode.
The app draws itself
with much lower detail so
it looks good with a reduced
number of pixels illuminated.
This would be great for
a navigation app.
When the user is not looking at
the display, the user saves power, but
the interface is ready to
be resumed to this one here
whenever the user wakes it up.
The user can dismiss the always-on
app when they have finished the task
they're performing.
But then they can control how
long this task happens for.
And finally, there are watch faces.
These are selected by the user
as the default watch face, and
the wearable shows this whenever
there is nothing else to show.
The user is going to be glancing at this
all day to find out what time it is, and
what important things there are that
are going on in their lives.